next in the series of uh the ucheshi
home
program is um haoi with the
Joe so you've done the Ken saures you've
done hairi with the Ken you've done Joe
saures all 20 trying to
um over time perap you're still working
through
them repetitions of five trying to get
three feeling the same then you then
we've gone on to doing um the Joe and
the Ken trying to feel the Ken seven Ken
saures done with the Joe and feeling
that uh they feel both the same and try
and remove your mind saying oh to at the
moment I've got a Joe my hand or at the
moment I've got a Ken in my hand so
we've got to this stage where we're
trying to uh make our body movement and
the actual movement the
same now we're going to move on
uh you've already done you should have
separated the 20 joose of
heres uh by just doing them in
repetitions in in uh in the earlier
films now hairi with the
Joe uh I suggested that you do uh shci
Cuts so what is the first
subari
and then you could do Hai one forward
one back replicate what you done with
the Ken exactly the same format same me
going through all again you're going to
do repetitions of five you're trying to
get three feeling the same when they do
feel the same you move on to four stages
of Direction so becomes the cross then
you do five stage six stages and then go
on to eight stages but don't be in a
rush and you're going to be doing it
with the
Joe hopefully you're going to do what
you've just done in the previous film is
you're going to make the Joe feel the
same as you H you felt with the
can the footwork has to be the same as
the can uh in this particular
stage we're building up footwork now and
Ken and Joe work so the body is at ease
no matter what you you really got in
your hands it must become part of your
makeup part of your your building of
Oneness if this item you're holding
feels different and feels separate then
you're not as one with your K or Joe
baseball bat or whatever it may be that
you're you're trying to become one with
so Hao with the Joe once you've found
that you can do three of these through
the whole eight directions with the Joe
the same as with the Ken you can then go
on to doing other things like the the
sixth subur or uh the seventh the
there's multiple different angles and
subur that you can add and add and add
this will be up to you but remember when
you add something let's suppose and you
decided to um with the Joe add the seven
uh kerb with the
Joe that's fine as long as you are look
still looking for the repetitions of
five and achieving three feeling the
same you're not just trying to add lots
of different movements for the sake of
you expanding your your knowledge field
of being able to C me up uh different uh
movements one that I love very much is
Huch uh because that way you're doing
you can do a whole 360 turn with the
feet is what you should be aiming for so
you do a
forwards and then hasso and back
forwards strike hasso back and then you
build up once you've done five of those
and three felt the same you do strike
hasso and then you turn with the hasso
and you strike the opposite
way
again five of those repetition of trying
to get three feeling the same same as
the K and Joe you then move on to four
movements six movements eight movements
each time small pause after each five
how did you get on did you get on did
you get three that felt uh the
repetition feel the same with your feet
as well as your hands your body um if
you the target is three it's very hard
to get just three um that you can repeat
time and time again and it might take
you years but but set this as a a
long-term goal you everybody wants it
next now everybody wants to do it
immediately but set it as a long-term
goal that you will achieve it you know
if you're determined and say I will
achieve it even if I don't now don't be
disheartened don't worry about it some
will work better than others you might
find that even six movements with the
Ken or Joe might be better than the four
movements the eight movements you you'll
find a niche where your body just seems
to feel happier in a certain segment
than than
others so uh uh then you do the haoi as
I said with the hasso movement once
you've done the S Ken subur with the
Joe I'd like you to move on to the using
the hasso so the hasso with a strike and
once you've achieved this then you can
start adding to the subur is but add
them with the hasso so they all start
with the hasso and then you can add um
the forward thrust you're going to add a
backward thrust
um your aim is to do the eight
directions and
eventually um you're aiming to do a
360 so you go all the way around to to
um you're you're start you're starting
with your Jo front of you you do the
hassle you go all the way around 360 and
you then you cut finally in the
direction that you started so you're
starting by holding the Joe you know
you're holding the Joe in front of
you in the Kamai uh posture and from
there you your your foot goes all the
way around and you come back to where
you first started in posture and you you
do a strong like and you're doing
repetitions again of five of these
aiming for three to feel the
same and this is the next stage of your
program by now if I'm correct you should
be up to 50
ukam uh forward ukam that is continuous
without um breathing stopping pausing
whatsoever and you should be up to about
35 um
backw Chamis without stopping and you're
getting fit if you're above that if
you're up to 60 80 forward ukis then
great uh one day my student was able to
do 200 UK Camis without stopping with
weights on his rests and on his feet not
too heavy but you know sand weights uh
couple of
a kilo each uh on each wrist so four
kilos added to it and he done 200
nonstop and um after four months this
was and training and living with me
every day so I don't expect you to get
to that because um only the very very
best um ever will
reach um I would say 100 without
stopping if you want to prove me wrong
then I'm more than happy that you do
this thank you for your time and again
if any of this is unclear please get in
touch with me and I'll go through it
slowly again on film or I will contact
you and uh go through it clearly my aim
is for you to get fitter and more
professional and above all love your
aido